I do I can't see the reading without
them it's so sad any glasses I don't
know if Lauren's out there with any
lipstick or even that lip balm I feel
like my my lips have turned into some
type of weird gum they look fine but I
know what you mean
all right welcome back to the juice news
podcast where we're giving you all the
quirky fun inspiring and yes informative
stories that exist in the world because
well we all need it right now and today
we're covering all the good vibe stories
that we could find from Kim K's million
dollar secret to the secret to a long
lasting marriage and this week I have
the perfect the best the most amazing
co-pilot to break it all down with
fellow podcaster himself life coach and
number one New York Times bestseller
author say hello to the one and only Jay
Shetty hey Drew thank you so much it's
great to be here ugh I just I love you
so much we've done the show many times
and thank you for gracing us with your
presence no thank you thank you I'm so
grateful to be here all right let's get
right into it our first story it was
revealed that Kim Kardashian has been
secretly donating Millions to families
in need she didn't ask for any
recognition and she was lauded for her
efforts at the baby to baby Gala an
organization near and dear to my heart I
love that she did this without posting
it and bragging about it showing it off
that is the true form of altruism give
back like wow it's unbelievable I'm so
happy that it came out I know me too I'm
actually really glad to know this
information yeah I think it's really
important I think you know there's a few
years ago Michael Norton and his team
did this study on whether we're happier
or whether money can make us happy right
like that was the the study and they
tested it out on two different groups
and one group they gave money to and
they said you have to spend this money
to yourself and so you have to spend
this money on yourself so they give them
five dollars and ten dollars and twenty
dollars and then they gave five ten
twenty dollars to a bunch of other
people and said you have to spend this
money on someone else you can't spend it
on yourself and then they were measuring
whether people were happier before or
after and what the happiness level
showed so first of the three things that
people spent money on were like
Starbucks makeup and Starbucks whether
they bought it for themselves or someone
else well if you looked at my credit
card receipts that's exactly what you
said things yeah but they found every
time that anyone who spent money on
others was 10 happier than the people
who just spent money on themselves so
the idea of giving back and giving away
is actually good for our own happiness
too so they said Michael Norton and his
team that money can buy you happiness if
you give it away it's so interesting
because you said when they gave people
money I was thinking like that sounds
nice what's What's wrong with that of
course that's going to make someone
happy and then you said it was the group
that got the money and had to spend it
on other people and I just was like oh
yeah it's true yeah like it's like we
talked about in your podcast like
forgiveness is like it ends up being
this incredibly amazing gift to oneself
you got to really forgive you can't
phone it in to get to the Forgiveness
but like when you are doing something
very giving it ironically has a
boomerang effect if it's really true if
the intentions really pure yes you're
doing it for the right reasons yes you
end up getting this bonus gift yes yes
that like you didn't do it for but you
can't like not have because it
boomerangs on you yeah it's not the
amount right like if you gave a million
dollars but with the intent of ego or
arrogance it won't feel good to you even
if and it will help people either way
but even if all you could afford was far
less than that and it was a dollar but
you gave it with all the love and all
the joy in the world that makes a huge
difference to you and that person too so
exactly and I will say that where this
woman who is fascinating and has
longevity I mean she's been keeping this
going for what feels like I mean how
long has Kim Kardashian been in our
universe like 20 years so I was going to
say two decades is what I feel okay
that's not easy to maintain that type of
sort of potency and presence and she has
she's an entrepreneur she's a smart
businesswoman when she with 300 million
followers is going into law is having
this phase of her life where like
Justice Reform and like these are her
goals missions and priorities and now
give backs it's like that is going to
influence also and have a trickle-down
effect to all the people that really
kind of hang under every move in words
absolutely so I I said I'm just a huge
this is this is great news in my opinion
okay next step a Minnesota woman Ida
Shannon turned 91 and celebrated by
going skydiving for the very first time
with her church group she's spent her
80th birthday zip lining she really
leveled up for 91. Jay do you see
yourself skydiving at 91 is there
something on your bucket list I I just
about sold myself skydiving at 34. I
think that's how old I was when I went
and that was only because I had a friend
who put me on the spot and I was I was
too nervous to say no to him and so that
so a week before I was asked do you want
to go skydiving next week and I said no
I would never go skydiving like no
chance and then he asked me the day
before he said do you want to go
skydiving and I said
okay because I felt the peer pressure I
didn't want to look like someone who was
scared like I'm not a wimp I could do
this exactly but I I would check I'm
wondering who allowed her to go
skydiving in 91 like I'm not sure that
that's like and there's like health
checks there and things like that like I
just want to be mindful like high five
what did I ask first I'm like which
which like which yeah which city or
state allowed were we monitoring her is
this gonna like be the thrill of the
lifetime too much yeah no I yeah I I
would not go skydiving at 91 unless we
did it together okay yeah let's do it
together I did it once too yeah and uh
my biggest takeaway from skydiving was
that if I ever wanted to experience uh
What uh sucking on a tailpipe that had
like diesel engines were like not
because of smoke or I should say if I
ever wanted to know what it was like to
put a leaf blower in my mouth uh that is
what Scott diving is nobody talks about
that your mouth is blown open and the
airbrushes in your mouth is already dry
from nerves and all you want to do is
take a breath and have a sip of water
yeah I felt like I was playing that game
what's that thing that they put in your
mouth say it something like you know yes
like that yeah that's what it is I
forgot what it's called but yes you know
what I'm talking about yeah yes yeah the
dental the dental thing that you put in
your mouth and then you have to say
words and people have to guess it back
and you literally feel like your whole
mouth is being that pulled back what I'm
talking about nobody talks about it
better better yeah Leaf flow is a good
that's like a leaf blower with your
mouth after you've had those Dental pull
things out I was like I can't breathe
um all right well we'll be right back to
serve you more news including a secret
to making a relationship work for over
70 years
[Music]
we are back everybody Bros are hitting
the books an all guys book club might
sound like a clever ruse for a poker
night or a fantasy football draft but
this is real the books and Brews book
club has been meeting for years and
diving into modern Classics like Eat
Pray Love fun home and wild Jay would
you ever start a book club with your
Bros and what is the last book you
couldn't put down so we try to stop one
once but it only had one session but the
one session was really good like we
really got somewhere and then everyone's
kind of attention dropped off but I I
definitely would and the book that we
chose which I've read separately which I
highly recommend to any men's book club
studying because of this podcast which
is Awesome by the way uh it's called The
Way of the superior man it's by David
data and it's a phenomenal book that I I
hope all men would read and it really
talks about masculinity what it truly
means to be a man how to truly behave
around
women how to truly behave around anyone
I mean it's a really brilliant book it's
called The Way of the superior man and I
highly recommend it to all men in my
life and I've read it at least two or
three times okay that is huge I love
that recommendation I want to read that
book as a woman yeah it would be well
once you read this woman you can be
recommending it to all the men in your
life well and then and then it might be
hard I mean yeah is there anyone in your
book club that we would know who was we
would know
I don't know I'm trying to
I don't know I'm not sure maybe
I had a we had a weird feeling that
maybe your book club was kind of had
some fun people in there
um all right next from Superman to super
dad actor Dean Kane revealed that he
gave up a huge career opportunity to
focus on raising his son as a single dad
he says it took him a split second to
choose focusing on his son what is your
advice if you are seeing a fork in the
road or an opportunity ahead of you but
maybe you know there's something on the
side that needs your attention well well
I think I'm going to go to what you said
on my podcast that we just recorded and
you said you know not to be morbid but I
really think you have to fast forward
you know you have to look at how that
decision will look in the future you
have to look at it from that future
vantage point so for me I often think
like how will I feel about what I'm
about to do in 10 20 30 40 50 years and
if I look at it from that perspective
I'm more likely to make a decision that
my future self will be proud of and so
that's what I try and think about like
what would my future self be proud of
what would my future self feel happy
about that I chose to do and I don't
think that can lead you wrong because
you you're tapping into your future
intention and intuition rather than
trying to make a logical pros and cons
decision which I think is fairly Limited
okay just for the record I said like not
to be more of it but at some point I'm
gonna die yes yes and I don't want to
live like this anymore but that's a good
place to start making decisions from
well and mine was in the spirit of I'm
so sick of this pattern if I don't kick
it now I'm not going to the Grave or
whenever death you know comes upon me
I'm just I refuse to still be in this
place what you just said is so
Illuminating because I people have said
like what's your Five-Year Plan or
what's your Port Vision I never have an
answer because I'm not really calculated
like I I don't really function that way
I fall in love with this thing in front
of me or I might have an idea of some
things I want to do and accomplish I
know it'll probably take a few years to
get there but I I've never been one of
those like business women who like has a
you know in 5 10 and 15 years this is
where I want to be I'm like I don't know
where I'm gonna be I just see this thing
in front of me that like is a fire I
cannot extinguish and I'm going to go
for it yeah what you just said is you
could have the ability to look at your
future self
and realize like what would you be proud
of
um and you probably hopefully will have
the gift of getting to that Future Self
so that's a very calming interesting way
to go because we're so stuck in the now
yeah yeah and and there is obviously
power in the now but I think that that's
not you can make decisions based on
Future Vision on the now right like so I
think in my own life as well there were
plenty of times it could be a career
switch right for me that's what it was
it was a career switch I was coming out
from being a monk I was working in the
corporate world and I wasn't happy and
satisfied doing that and I was like well
maybe I should start following my
purpose which is what I do today and I
was like scared I was scared I was like
I knew nothing about media I knew
nothing about social media I knew
nothing about entertainment I had no
family in the business and I thought to
myself I was like well if I don't try my
90 year old self is going to be really
upset with me for not giving this a go
so at least give it a go now I'm not
going to be upset that I did try and
failed but I'm going to be upset that I
never tried oh my God I'm gonna be now
asking my future self things all the
time and like I'll be texting you Jay
and telling you about it I love it
um okay last one one of the best ones
it's a little love advice from 200 year
olds who have been married for a
whopping
79 years
and it sounds amazing you might have
done with your toddler June and Hubert
mallacoat say the secret to a long
lasting love is a quick time out
walking away for a minute helps
de-escalate so that you can regroup and
work it out
ah I love this so much Jay what is the
best piece of relationship advice that
you've ever received well there's so
much that I could share I think received
is hard I don't think I've received much
good relationships advice if I'm
completely honest but one thing I was
thinking about today I was uh I was
talking to Dr Robert waldinger who's uh
head of Psychiatry at Harvard and he's
just super awesome as he's incredible
um we had him on my podcast earlier but
we were talking about his book The Good
Life right that's who I'm following
perfect
well Joe Jonas is next so you know it's
it's a good it's a good uh good cocktail
wait we had a story about him on the
news oh oh never mind he was like he was
saying like listen men have vanity
things too oh yeah which I appreciate it
yeah and so but we were talking about
this and and I was saying this this
thing that I've been thinking about a
lot especially when you say a 79-year
marriage like that's really impressive
right so the thing that I think applies
to that is something I called new old
and old new and what I mean by that is
when I meet someone new I try to find an
old connection we have so maybe we grew
up in the same city or maybe maybe of a
friend or a family member that has the
same career like you try and find
something that connects you that's old
but when you're in an old relationship a
relationship that's been 79 years or
like you said your closest friend 40
years going strong I try and look for
something new so if you have an old
relationship look for something new and
if you have a new relationship look for
something old then it allows you to just
create this beautiful bond with someone
darn it Jay Shetty
every single time I also want to pull
over something that you said when we
were talking in your podcast that I
would be so grateful to share with
anyone who may be listening over here in
our little area which is that when I
asked you about you know I I opened up
and I asked you
we were just talking about like you know
I I have all these loves in my life my
kids my friends my co-workers who are my
family they're not co-workers I don't
work with people in a professional sense
I work with people in a professional
setting but in a personal sense
and you talked about how we put romantic
love on a pedestal
and sometimes our cups run us over and
we shouldn't lose sight of all the love
we have
just in case there's not that romantic
love in the picture too and that we as a
society have built this up to such Grand
proportions that some people think that
they're lacking if they don't have that
love and the way that you described it
has really made me feel good about I do
feel so whole I do feel my cup runneth
over my life is so fulfilling and I
almost ask myself sometimes because you
don't have that romantic love is
something missing I don't feel like it
does but I almost needed permission or I
needed an answer to just feel whole and
the one you gave me about how we put
romantic love on a pedestal and it
shouldn't take away from all the other
love that is really real and there was
so eye-opening for me oh thank you and I
um so I just wanted to share that with
everybody because it's something I will
be carrying with me the same as the old
new Theory yeah that's so beautiful no I
think we live in this world where like
if you grew up and you know when you
were growing up and you were a child and
not many people showed up to your
birthday party then you were unpopular
or if you're at school and you sat alone
at the lunch table then you were a loner
and when you grow up and you go to a
wedding and you don't have a plus one
it's like oh poor you right and it's
like every time you've been spending
time alone it was always made to feel
like you were less than or that you
didn't have something figured out or
there was something wrong with you or
there was a weakness and so I think it's
been so deeply ingrained and programmed
that today I know so many people as I
was saying I know so many people who
have an amazing you know they have
amazing children but they feel
unfulfilled just because they don't have
a partner they have an amazing career
they love but they feel unfulfilled if
they don't have a partner or they have
an amazing relationship with their
parents and Friends friends and family
and go on the best vacations and the
best trips but they feel unfulfilled I
think a lot of that is programming and
I'm not saying that we shouldn't have a
beautiful partner in our life and that's
wonderful if you do but you shouldn't
also feel incomplete if you don't right
so yeah and don't not recognize every
yes thing that is real and in front of
you yes ah Chase shut it hey God I love
you so much and as always you know this
is the new podcast for us so we're one
of the very first people to come on our
show when no one knew what it was in the
height of the pandemic and there were
crickets on tumbleweeds rolling in the
studio because no one was here and we
were filming a show like Wayne's World
so thank you thank you very inextricably
linked for me with embarking on this
journey and I I did want to have this be
this open-hearted
conversation destination
um and you're doing it and you're doing
it amazingly you know incredibly I mean
your presence on to have your presence
on TV every day and for everyone to see
you and the energy that you're putting
out there through any of your channels
any of your platforms that you share
yourself through
we need it we really need you right now
like it's unbelievable it's so inspiring
to watch it's so effortlessly beautiful
it's so elegant and graceful it's
unbelievable and I'm so grateful that I
get to be a small part of it but I I
really mean that I really mean that it's
it's been so refreshing so refreshing
coming from the man I stalked to come on
this show because I thought that if if I
could have a conversation with you early
on we might actually establish that
these kind of conversations can take
place and you planted the flag in the
sand for us you made it okay and you let
people know that we can have all
different types of conversations here so
I am forever grateful to you well well I
want you to know that the pressure's
often the other way around when you
invited me on I was like oh gosh I'm not
funny at all I was like this is gonna go
I was like this is gonna go miserably I
was like what am I going to do on Drew's
news
and then and then you actually allowed
me to just be myself and I was like oh
yeah this is good I could do this
because we need everything too much
funny is you know too much of a good
thing yeah like too serious and heavy
like it's too much yeah and also you are
the gift with making inner work and
spirituality and wellness and
self-awareness and works in progress you
are making that cool and attainable do
you know how many errors have been shut
off because it just got so heavy or you
just thought the person delivering the
message was not for you or wouldn't you
wouldn't engage with them off subject
like you brought like so much to this
field like we all need juice so right
back at you the ball went right over to
your court and I love you Jay Shetty I
love you thank you well thank you and
you have an upcoming book eight rules of
Love well I'm gonna be reading that
um how to find it keep it and let it go
okay that's on sale January 31st 20 23
three you know you can get it available
for a pre-order I'm certainly going to
be ordering it right after we leave this
room thank you I love you Jason I love
you too thank you everybody for
listening follow the Drew's News podcast
wherever you get your podcast and if you
like you know you can tell a friend or
you know tell their friends to tell
their friends and you know
um your family or your co-workers you
could tell your pet you know I talked to
Douglas and Lucy my dogs all the time
Luke Lucy and and Peach I talk to them I
talk to people in the grocery store you
could definitely tell them there and be
sure to watch the Drew Barrymore show
every weekday by going to the
drewberrymore show.com and you can find
your local channel time show look you
can watch it on YouTube you can't build
it anymore and think they will come you
got to build it and go find them where
they are so trust me we're probably
somewhere that you're already watching
and as always we make this show for you
so please take it
[Music]
thank you so much thank you so much
thank you so much